Now, we know a bunch about how you may
encode information into your visualization and how to make an
effective visualization, but we still haven't yet discussed how you
can make graphics like this, short of drawing them with
pen and paper. There are a number of packages
for plotting in Python. One of the most popular is
Matplotlib. For this course, however, I'd like to go over
plotting using a Python library called ggplot, which very closely
recreates the syntax used in R's ggplot2 library.
If Matplotlib is so widely used, why should we
use ggplot? Well, I'd like to use this package
for a few reasons. First, what it produces is
a bit more aesthetically pleasing than Matplotlib. Second, it's
an implementation of a pretty neat concept called the
grammar of graphics, which basically claims that there's a
grammar involved in composing graphical components of statistical graphics.
The gg in ggplot actually comes from
grammar of graphics. It also plays nicely with
the pandas DataFrames we've been using in
this course. To quickly summarize the ideas behind
the grammar of graphics, plots convey information
through their aesthetics such as x-position or y-position.
The elements in a given plot are
geometric shapes, such as points, lines, or bars.
Some of these shapes can have aesthetics of
their own, such as their size or their
color. You can think of creating plots in
ggplot through the grammar of graphics as adding layers
to our plot. The first step in creating
a graphic is always to create our plot, which
is essentially going to be our canvas. This
can be done by calling ggplot data aes(xvar, yvar).
Data here is going to be a pandas DataFrame, and xvar and yvar are going to be
columns in that data frame. So what we're doing
here is saying let's make a ggplot. The data
source is going to be our data frame,
and the quantities that we're interested in plotting are
xvar and yvar. This might be district and number
of Aadhaar enrollments or position and number of players,
something like that. So what we've done here is
we've made our ggplot. We've said that the data source
that it will use is pandas DataFrame, and that the
variables that we'll look at are xvar and yvar. This
might be district and number of Aadhaar enrolled if were
using our Aadhaar data or team and total number of
players if we were using our baseball data, something like
that. Okay, so, so far that we've said that we'll
have a plot which is mapping xvar to the
x-axis, yvar to the y-axis, but we haven't said yet
what type of geometric object is going to represent
this data. So if we add plus geom point to
this statement, we'll create a scatter plot. If we
also add plus geom line to the graphic, we'll connect
all these points to each other with lines. Now, say
that we wanted these points to have a particular color.
We can pass color equals coral into geom point,
and also pass color equals coral into geom line.
And after we do that, both the points and
the lines will have the color coral. This is the
second step of making a plot in ggplot, that
is choosing which type geometric objects will represent the data.
The final step here is going to be adding
some labels so that our plot will have some context,
like a title or an x-label or a y-label. This can be done much in the same way
that we added the points and lines to our
plot. We can add a ggtitle to title our
plot. An xlab, which will be x-label, to provide
an x-label. And a ylab to do the same
with the y-axis. Now all I have to do
is precede this entire command by Print. And I'll produce
a plot in Python. Why don't you try implementing
these ideas to create a graphic of your own?